[Aplausos]
amerizaje en el atlántico y aplausos
entusiastas cuando la primera
tripulación civil enviada al espacio
regreso a la tierra la cápsula dragón de
la firma spaces piloteada se suceden los
ángeles amerizó delante de la costa de
florida a las 7 de la noche hora local
después de tres días orbitando alrededor
de la tierra los cuatro ciudadanos
astronautas a bordo de la cápsula se
sumergieron de nuevo en la atmósfera
inferior de la tierra la comunicación se
perdió por unos siete minutos hasta que
recibieron este mensaje inspiration ford
en nombre de spacex bienvenidos a casa
al planeta tierra su misión le ha
demostrado al mundo que el espacio es
para todos nosotros que la gente común y
corriente puede lograr impactos
extraordinarios en el mundo
felicitaciones por su viaje
extraordinario después de tan sólo seis
meses de prepararse para las fuerzas
extremas de despegue de gravedad cero la
tripulación civil despegó el miércoles
desde el cabo cañaveral en florida a
bordo de un cohete falcon 9 reutilizable
fabricado por la empresa space ex del
multimillonario elon musk la cápsula de
la tripulación alcanzó una altitud
orbital de más de 85 km más alta que la
estación espacial internacional o el
telescopio espacial hubble y lo más
lejos que un ser humano ha volado desde
que el programa apolo lunar de la nasa
terminó en 1972 una inspiración para la
humanidad y un salto gigante hacia la
democratización del espacio